a spectacular flyover the traditional
start to France's Bastille Day Parade
French president Emmanuel macro
inspecting troops before greeting his
guest of honor Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi the leaders watched Indian
forces alongside their French
counterparts on paris's Shaw's Lisa the
military display was a fitting backdrop
to a raft of military deals later
discussed by the two leaders at the
Elysee Palace India plans to buy more
French Jets and submarines the two also
promised a deepened cooperation and said
they shared concerns about climate
change and the war in Ukraine
I think we are equally worried by the
fragmentation of the International
Community in particular in the context
of Russia's war in Ukraine and have the
same goal which is lasting peace ending
in to respond to the impact of this war
of aggression on vulnerable countries
the consequences of the covert pandemic
and the conflict in Ukraine are felt all
over the world the impacts are
particularly felt by the countries of
the global South the invitation to Modi
isn't only about trade and closer ties
France is one of a growing number of
Western Powers looking to bolster India
to counter growing Chinese influence in
the region
the French president's decision to woo
the Indian leader though has angered
some these protesters say Modi in his
Hindu nationalist party are eroding
human rights in India particularly those
of religious minorities including
Muslims and Christians I mean State
Powers they have to talk they have to
negotiate we understand that but on
particular this day vasude is a symbolic
right it's our symbol it's a symbol of
equality of fraternity Liberty and um
and it's like
is not really respecting his own country
his own country's principles
the macro it's not only been about
playing host the festivities have
provided an opportunity to focus on
National Unity after some difficult days
it's more than two weeks since violence
broke out in parts of France following
the killing of a teenager by a police
officer in a Paris suburb extra police
have been deployed across the country to
try and keep the peace my cross
certainly won't want any new unrest
marring France's national holiday was
Sasha Butler Al Jazeera Paris